bonjour et bienvenue à bruxelles au
parlement européen pour ce nouveau
numéro de grand theft auto et dans cette
émission nous irons à madrid nous
entendrons le désarroi de cette jeunesse
espagnole qui a longtemps campé sur la
puerta del sol mais d'abord l'actualité
l'europe peut-elle encore sauver la
grèce au bord du gouffre
c'est la question de la semaine depuis
des mois le temps était à l'orage cette
fois la foudre a frappé sur l'acropole
le coup a été porté par standard and
poor's l'agencé de notation a abaissé de
trois crans la note de crédit à long
terme du pays à deux points seulement du
défaut de paiement
en clair plus personne ne croit à thème
capable d'honorer ses obligations
le pays croule sous le poids d'une dette
sans fin à quoi donc ont servi les 110
milliards d'euros accordé par l'europe
il y a un an avec l'appui financier du
fmi et les nouveaux milliards de
rallonge promis aujourd'hui suffiront
ils à sauver le pays
car les aides de l'europe et du fmi sont
donnés à une condition la promesse d'une
extrême rigueur mais jusqu'à quand le
peuple crie sa colère contre les mesures
d'austérité imposées par le gouvernement
des efforts digne des douze travaux
d'hercule
le chômage explose les ressources se
tarissent et les pauvres n'ont plus rien
à donner
l'état avons privatisé les banques les
services publics et les plages
rien n'y fait le mur de la dette est là
et le pays au bord du gouffre alors
peut-on encore sauver la grèce
voilà pour le tableau sombre de la
situation de la grèce nous sommes avec
robert rochefort bonjour un jours merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
européen ou siéger au groupe
l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe vous êtes
économiste sociologue avec plusieurs
casquettes alors parlons franchement les
grecs aujourd'hui sont confrontés à une
dette colossale
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
athènes a les moyens de rembourser cette
dette gigantesque ou alors est-ce que
c'est la faillite qui est annoncé en
tout cas nous l'europe nous avons tout à
fait les moyens de venir en aide à la
grèce la grèce d'ailleurs comme si on
rajoute le portugal et l'irlande ont des
pays très très important mais leur point
économique globale par rapport à
l'ensemble de l'union c'est 6%
donc si les autres pays de l'union en
particulier sont que des mesures d
économie plus forte sont capables d
s'entendent entre eux et c'est la
question de ces jours ci évidemment on
peut sauver la grèce est évidemment il
faut sauver la grèce simplement il faut
que la grèce ne soit plus avec des taux
d'intérêt qui sont des taux d'intérêt
trop élevés il faut que la dette soit
plus étalé dans le temps et puis il faut
surtout que le peuple grec on vient de
voir quelques images
il faut que le peuple grec et des
perspectives positives c'est à dire
qu'on soit capable de proposer autre
chose que simplement les pleurs et les
larmes c'est à dire qu'on soit en même
temps dans un sentier de dynamisation de
la croissance évidemment alors vous
dites aujourd'hui l'europe a encore les
moyens de l'insu de sauver la grèce il
faut le faire mais en même temps il ya
un an on s'en souvient la situation
était déjà catastrophique dans le pays
l'europe a volé au secours d'athènes
avec un plan gigantesque de 110
milliards d'euros
que sont devenus ces 110 milliards
d'euros mis nommément ça n'a pas suffi
puisque aujourd'hui à ça près la même
somme sur la même voie était suffisant
et la même somme va être mise sur la
table mais vous
et bien que ça dépend comment cette
somme est organisée à quel taux
d'intérêt est ce que par exemple on ne
pourrait pas faire en sorte que cette
dette grecque devienne une dette
européenne en euros une dette globale
une dette de l'union européenne et pas
simplement une dette de la grèce c'est à
dire qu'il y ait un élément de
solidarité plus forts qu'ils soient fait
vis-à-vis de la grèce avec des taux
d'intérêt qui serait plus faible mais
évidemment il faut aussi que la grèce
s'engage dans des réformes des choses se
font au grès des choses sont en train de
démarrer mais évidemment si on voulait
avoir en quelques mois
l'intégralité de la mise en place du
plan de rigueur alors que le taux de
chômage chez les jeunes chez les jeunes
le taux de chômage en grèce il est y
avoisine les 50 ans on n'est pas loin
des 50%
c'est évidemment tout à fait dramatique
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
solution que vous proposez par exemple
de plus de solidarité européenne ce
qu'on pensait que les allemands seraient
prêts à faire ce geste a aidé comme ça
la question difficile
vous savez que les allemands veulent la
question principale ce qu'ils veulent
c'est pied une partie des d infondées
des prêteurs privés des banques privées
qu'ils soient associés comme landing au
destin de la dette grecque ça c'est une
bonne solution pour vous écouter je
pense pas que c'est la solution idéale
mais je pense que l'union européenne est
tombé d'accord sur le principe
et après comme très souvent en europe ce
qui coince et savoir comment on le fait
d'un point de vue pratique mais ce que
je voudrais dire est que pour moi le
plus important c'est qu'on ne sortira de
cette crise en grèce comme dans tous les
pays d'europe du sud et aussi en france
d'ailleurs que si il y à une politique
différente qui consiste par exemple à
faire en sorte que l'euro ne soit plus
défendu dans sa cotation par rapport au
dollar nous sommes à 1 40 dollar il
faudrait tout soyons à 1,20 1,15 à 1,20
pour que nous soyons dans des parité
équitable qui permette de relancer les
productions en europe qui permette de
relancer des exportations et dont il
stimule l'économie grecque
y compris d'ailleurs dans sa composante
touristique artisanales ou sarah certain
nombre de composantes industrielles dont
si nous ne faisons pas à côté de cela
une politique comment dire qu'il soit
une politique beaucoup plus de soutien à
l'activité qui passe en particulier par
cours qui soit un cours plus équitable
avec le dollar nous n'arriverons à rien
donc la grèce finalement elle est une
maquette
elle est un modèle réduit et nous voyons
que si nous ne prenons pas les décisions
qu'il faut c'est en fait l'ensemble de
l'europe qui est qui qui se retrouvent
malades un modèle réduit peut-être mais
en attendant la de la situation semble
semble très graves sur sur place la
population se mobilise
ils disent on en a marre de faire des
efforts nous n'avons plus rien plus
d'argent à donner ce que la situation
peut dégénérer quand il ya une colère
sociale qui monte oui oui bien sûr en
grèce et ailleurs aussi bien sûr bien
sûr bien sûr elle elle peut dégénérer
mais avec dégénérera dans quelle nature
par rapport à quoi
quel est le plan b pour la grèce si le
plan b pour la grèce c'est de sortir de
l'euro et c'est de sortir d'une certaine
façon de l'union européenne en tout cas
de l'eurozone
c'est pas un vrai plan b c'est à dire
que les les grecs ne vont pas à ce
moment là dans quelque chose qui
facilitera leur situation bien au
contraire parce que vous voyez bien que
si la grèce sort de la zone euro elle ne
trouvera même plus de prêteurs
par rapport à une monnaie qui serait une
monnaie complètement d'évaluer à court
terme
cela donnerait peut-être le sentiment
qu'elle pourrait exporter plus
facilement mais ce serait de toute façon
cinq ou dix ans de galère
en tout état de cause donc il faut que
la grèce fasse des efforts mais il faut
en même temps que les grecs retrouvent
espoir et pour cela il faut qu'on ait un
message nous l'union européenne sans
ambiguïté par rapport à la grèce nous ne
la laisserons pas tomber
et quel est le message que doit adresser
selon vous l'europe à ces marchés qui
quand même continue pour certains à
spéculer sur l'éclatement de la seconde
à bord en flèche peut-être aux agences
de notation que dans les années 30 elle
avait déjà dégradé la note de la grèce
de façon très très importante provoquant
une chute encore plus important de la
grèce un défaut de paiement de la grèce
qui d'ailleurs ensuite a été par les
agences de notation considèrent comme
une erreur parce que vous voyez que le
problème des agences de notation c'est
qu'elles ont des prophéties
autoréalisatrices parce que plus elles
dégradent la note plus elles elles font
que effectivement la dette devient une
dette de très mauvaise qualité
donc là il faut vraiment qu'elle
réfléchisse à ça je crois que la réforme
des agences de notation et en
particulier la fête le fait de devoir ou
pas côté les dettes souveraines des
états c'est vraiment un sujet qui
continue est devant nous et qui est pas
nouveau dans l'histoire
eh bien merci robert rochefort c'est en
tout cas à l'agenda européen merci
d'avoir été notre invité une femme fait
aussi l'actualité européenne christine
lagarde ministre française de l'économie
et candidate officielle à la succession
de dominique strauss kahn pour prendre
la tête du fmi comment est-elle vu en
europe
regardez ce tour d'horizon des
télévisions
elle est en pôle position pour décrocher
l'un des postes les plus influents du
monde
christine lagarde ministre française de
l'économie est favorite dans la course à
la direction générale du fmi
son concurrent c'est luis augusto
carstens gouverneur de la banque
centrale du mexique et ancien numéro
trois du fmi
ils font campagne aux quatre coins du
monde
portugal inde chine je suis extrêmement
satisfaite après d accueil tout à fait
positif dans chacune de ces régions
merci très confiante je ne vais pas me
mentir je sais ce que c'est de commencer
un match de foot avec un handicap de 5
buts
je peux finir avec 5 3 ou 5 partout où
même finir vainqueur mais ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'en comment ce match avec cinq
buts de retard
les chants sont minimes l'indonésie est
le premier grand pays émergent a apporté
son soutien à la candidature de
christine lagarde pour la direction
générale du fonds monétaire
international en déplacement en egypte
la ministre française des finances a
également obtenu le soutien de l'egypte
mais aussi des émirats arabes unis
c'est important car christine lagarde en
l'absence de soutien officiel des états
unis jusqu'à maintenant doit gagner la
confiance de pays émergents relativement
important bien que la chine l'inde et
les états unis ne se soit pas encore
prononcé
lagarde fait déjà figure de favorite le
conseil d'administration du fmi a
jusqu'au 30 juin pour prendre sa
décision
voilà et pour commenter ces images avec
nous christophe garage bonjour vous êtes
journalistes européens à vous suivez ici
harcèlent les affaires européennes alors
christine lagarde grande favorite mais
est ce que pour autant les jeux sont
faits moi ce que je constate c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y à une quasi
unanimité
du côté des européens quelles que soient
les la grandeur des pays et surtout
l'allemagne a finalement accepté de
soutenir christine lagarde
non sans hésiter on a vu aussi des
hésitations du côté des belges on a vu
une tentation polonaises puis très vite
il s'est avéré que le candidat devait
être un candidat issu de la zone euro et
donc les jeux se sont resserrés autour
de christine lagarde
vous avez été dans les coulisses de ce
fameux sommet de l'eurogroupe déjà le
nom de christine lagarde circulait à
peine l'annoncent fait de l'arrestation
de dominique strauss kahn
pourquoi ça a été aussi est-ce que ça a
été très rapide et et comment est-ce que
le nom de christine lagarde
l'allemand s'est imposé moi ce que je
constate aussi c'est que les européens
ont quand même changé d'avis souvenez
vous en 2007 quand je troskan a été
nommé il était quasiment acquis
d'ailleurs jean claude juncker le
président de l'eurogroupe
la veggie ce serait le dernier candidat
européen à ce poste entre temps la crise
est passée par là quelle crise pour la
zone euro la crise de la dette
et puis c'est vrai au lendemain même de
l'arrestation de dominique strauss kahn
la petite musique est venue d'allemagne
de berlin qui disait quoi
s'il doit y avoir un successeur à
strauss kahn ce sera un européen est
effectivement très rapidement le nom de
christine lagarde s'est imposé non sans
quelques hésitations je rappelle qu'à ce
stade
au delà de toutes les déclarations des
grands états membres des petits pays etc
il n'y a pas de communiqué officiel pour
dire que l'europe soutient
officiellement christine lagarde
le chacun s'est exprimé à son nom propre
le président du conseil européen le
président de l'eurogroupe
les grands états les grands chefs d'état
de gouvernement et pas de communiquer au
plus officielle peut-être qu'on attend
encore les conséquences de l'affairé
tapie ces salles épée de damoclès
j'allais dire parce que à ce jour on ne
sait pas encore si christine lagarde
dans sa fonction de ministre de
l'économie va ou non faire l'objet d'une
enquête pour avoir choisi dans certains
faire tapis là la procédure d'arbitrage
est ce que c'est gênant quand même qu
est-ce qui dit que si finalement attendu
mois elle et elle est investi à la tête
du fmi
elle ne risque pas de démissionner comme
son prédécesseur avant elle moi j'ai cru
comprendre que les français avaient
bétonné cette question dans les
chancelleries pour dire que a priori ne
devrait pas y avoir de problème je
constate aussi que les belge didier
reynders le ministre des communes et des
finances s'est très vite affiché comme
un possible recours si au dernier moment
christine lagarde l'accord de
candidature
oui et non rijnders pourquoi pas c'est
un anglophone enfin francophone d'abord
mais il part très bien l'anglais il
connaît parfaitement la zone euro ont la
même à un moment donné pressenti pour
présider la zone euro à la place de
juncker
donc pourquoi pas en quelques mots est
ce que christine lagarde a le bon profil
pour prendre la tête du fmi
elle possède beaucoup d'atouts d'abord
ne serait ce que pour sur un plan
européen
quand vous êtes malades gravement malade
vous allez voir un médecin qui doit être
compétent qui al'expertise qui connaît
de qui connaît la maladie la zone euro
aujourd'hui elle a besoin d'un médecin
qui connaît sa maladie son
fonctionnement est donc sûre sur ce
point là c'est essentiel pour la zone
euro d'avoir quelqu'un qui sait de quoi
on parle aujourd'hui pour sortir la zone
euro de l'ornière
eh bien merci christophe garage pour ce
commentaire je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef adjoint d'euros parle
tv alors on parler de la crise de
confiance dans la zone euro il ya aussi
une crise de confiance plus générale en
europe la colère monte notamment en
espagne nous sommes allés à la rencontre
de cette jeunesse espagnole qui a tenu
le pavé sur la place costa del sol à
madrid
portrait de ces indignés avec anaïs goût
batian et on retrouve après françois vos
données et son invité on va faire un
petit tour par ici
laetitia vit à madrid depuis dix ans le
camp de la puerta del sol n'a plus de
secret pour elle
depuis le premier jour elle fait partie
des indignés à la le corps une formation
non
donc c'est la honte avoir toutes les
informations les voûtes les questions
tout ça comment tu as ta vie c'est
vraiment compliqué ici les prix ont
augmenté à une vitesse hallucinante
les salaires n'ont pas du tout suivi et
on a beau être non diplômés polyglotte
et 1 voilà que ça veut pas du tout dire
qu'on va avoir un travail n'est qu'on
pourra se débrouiller tout seul à la fin
du mois allenbach presse à 23 ans
laetitia fini ses études pour être
assistante sociale chômage éclatement de
la bulle immobilière en espagne mais
surtout la crise financière de 2008
petit à petit elle a vu ses amis perdre
leur emploi leur logement est souvent
retourné vivre chez leurs parents
pour résumer une pancarte qu'elle est
ici utilisé le seuil anti système à
système assane diop
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disaient
qu'on était des anti système des punks à
chiens avec
qui avait rien d'autre à faire de leur
vie que de venir camper au milieu d'eux
seuls et donc à tout un mouvement qui
s'est mis en place pour dire mais
regardez ces panneaux qui s'avoue contre
le système c'est le système qui est
contre nous les jeunes fer de lance de
ce mouvement d'indignation mais pas
seulement
parmi les curieux qui visitent le camp
laetitia croiser le chemin de ricardo à
67 ans ce retraité soutient complètement
le monde
est-ce que je compose chez une amie à la
fiancée comme un tsunami mais un plomb
mamie positif les consciences bouche de
la part des espagnols mais aussi elle
d'autres personnes dans les autres pays
ici il y a beaucoup de problèmes plus
que dans d'autres pays industrialisés
il y a le chômage qui touche surtout les
jeunes les jeunes ne peuvent pas trouver
de logement parce que leurs salaires
sont trop bas en dessous de la moyenne
européenne
le salaire minimum en espagne est de 630
euros en france
il est deux fois plus élevé mais par
dessus tout les indignes à dos
reprochent à leurs dirigeants politiques
de vivre dans un autre monde que de ne
pas comprendre leur réalité
un sentiment qui pousse beaucoup
d'espagnols à venir signer la pétition
de soutien au mouvement
je crois qu'ils ont raison le monde ne
peut plus avancer comme ça nous sommes
en train de le détruire et dans ce pays
par dessus tout il ya une quantité
incroyable de personnes congo le
problème c'est que les gens leur ont
fait confiance et ont voté pour eux donc
la situation empire
la corruption c'est la responsable de la
disparition de la démocratie il y avait
une facilité très grande par rapport aux
pouvoirs publics est censé nous
représenter et en fait non seulement
santé par représenter mais en plus on
avait pratiquement aucun intérêt pour ce
qui se passait à bon d'accord ils ont
fait ça à d'accord ils ont voté ça
et en fait
depuis trois semaines partout dans le
métro absolument partout on entend
tellement parler de la politique de ce
qui devrait se faire dès ce qui devrait
changer et donc rien que pour ça je
pense que le mouvement est déjà un
avenir mais les indignés sont de moins
en moins nombreux dans le camp au bout
de trois semaines il est temps de
quitter la puerta del sol
une décision difficile à prendre et
largement discuté en assemblée générale
le consensus à tout prix c'est la grande
force de ce mouvement mais c'est aussi
parfois sa faiblesse
finalement au bout de cinq heures la
grande majorité qu'on va la dizaine de
réfractaires soulagé je suis soulagé
dans le sens où on avait vraiment besoin
d'une date de départ parce que ça
devenait bien compris car
l'intérieur est donc ça c'est l'anglais
maintenant qu'on a une date de départ on
va centrer sur comment rester dans les
quartiers et ça c'est vraiment le
et l'idée du mois sol s'en va mais ne
s'éteint pas c'est en tout cas ce qu'ils
espèrent tous des comités de quartier
ont été créés partout en espagne pour
lutter et pour faire remonter les
problèmes
difficile de dire aujourd'hui si ce
mouvement aura de réelles répercussions
sur la vie des espagnols s'il fera
vraiment bouger les choses
en tout cas un espoir est né chez
beaucoup de jeunes la baisse atteint
l'europe voilà stade rigaud un reportage
signé à madrid d'anaïs vous battions
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par miguel ángel martinez
bonjour vous êtes député européen
espagnol vous êtes vice-président du
parlement européen où nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui est ce que vous diriez que
les jeunes espagnols convient de voir
dans ce reportage sont dans un désarroi
est ce que le mot désarroi est quelque
chose qui vous convient et je crois que
le monde est à wasmes convient
particulièrement
on a beaucoup parlé d'un d'indignation
même les indignés en fait en est ce que
c'est plutôt du désarroi l'indignation
est quelque chose de partager un instant
particulier par la droite il s'est
montré indigné dix dernières années qui
est sorti non pas par quelques milliers
mais par quelques centaines de milliers
dans les rues contre la loi sur le
mariage des homosexuels ou contre
l'introduction d'une matière
d'enseignement qui s'appelle l'éducation
pour la démocratie donc l'indignation
est une est un concept différent
je pense que qu'il ya un très grand
désarroi
est exposé en raison de faire ça pardon
est-ce qu'ils ont raison de faire ça
qu'ils aient raison il ya des raisons
pour faire ça sans aucun doute mais le
le désarroi si vous voulez le fruit
quand même d'une situation particulière
et est aussi de la vitesse des
changements en espagne et arrière il ya
déjà des centaines de milliers de jeunes
qui entre autres sont allés à
l'université ont des diplômes ils ont
tous des diplômés ils sont et ils sont
allés à l'université parce qu'il ya eu
des changements fondamentaux dans notre
système bien il ya trente ans cela
n'était même pas envisageable
aujourd'hui tout le monde à l'université
il ya beaucoup de gens ont tout le monde
peut aller à l'université il ya des gens
qui se retrouvent avec des diplômes et
qui ne trouvent pas pour autant ni la
considération sociale ni surtout le la
possibilité de travail qu'on a toujours
identifié avec le diplôme on se retrouve
avec un diplôme mais sans pouvoir
travailler dans le domaine et que ce
diplôme justifierait ou même sans
pouvoir travailler du tout non alors
sans travail on a pas on n'a pas la
possibilité de se développer de
s'émanciper par rapport aux gens de
rester chez leurs parents d'avoir un
logement de conserver une famille si on
en a envie
donc donc on est vraiment dans une
situation qui pousse au désarroi quand
on est un peu dans la sémantique est ce
que vous diriez que cette génération est
une génération sacrifiée
écoutez c'est une génération où pour la
première fois c'est ce qui ce qui
définit la situation c'est une
génération qui pour la première fois
craint à juste titre de vivre moins bien
que leurs parents et amis pendant
pendant des siècles en espagne comme
partout en europe on a toujours pensé et
que qu'on vivrait mieux que nos parents
et nos parents ont toujours cru que nous
allions vivre mieux que pour la première
fois une génération qui qui se posent
un grand point d'interrogation
consciente d'ailleurs des skates de ski
est là une bonne formation et elle vit
dans une dans une cité dans une
situation d'insécurité
quant à son avenir et à juste titre elle
pense que probablement il va moins vivre
moins bien que ses parents ses
grands-parents
l'une des raisons évidemment de ceux de
ces manifestations de mécontentement et
de et de désarroi c'est le chômage des
jeunes qui est très très marqué en
espagne
il est également marquée alors un peu
moins heureusement mais en tout cas dans
le reste de l'europe est ce que vous
pensez que la situation espagnole ce
désarroi des jeunes espagnols est le
même un peu partout en europe
je pense qu'il est qu'il est qu'il est
il est même dans des contextes
différents
moi je retrouve je retrouve chez le ch
et ces jeunes je retrouve avec une
grande nostalgie et avec une grande
tendresse des choses que j'ai vécues en
68 à paris
c'est comparable c'est comparable dans
ce sens qu'il ya le même réflexe de
refus d'une société est absolument
injuste et injuste à leur égard aussi
mais injuste sans jamais se poser la
question
nous on a des possibilités que nos
parents n'ont jamais les us et leurs
parents avaient un train on peut en
prenez le train est une petite valise en
carton souvent pour s'en aller
travailler en france en angleterre en
allemagne en belgique là la chose ne
s'oppose au pratiquement pas pour pour
ces jeunes 68 on a vu ce que ça a donné
après là ça peut déboucher sur quoi les
indignés qui sont alors en espagne on
laisse penser qu'ils sont ça fait ça
fait déboucher
moi je crains que ça fasse débouchés
comme d'ailleurs mai 68 a travaillé sa
fin ça fait déboucher sur des
raz-de-marée qui amène la droite et la
droite la plus dure au pouvoir d'abord
parce qu'il ya l'indignation de ses
jeunes et de quelques centaines de
milliers même je suis présent pas prêts
à mettre le jeune homme ayant la peur et
l'indignation de
lyon de citoyens de citoyens romains il
ya deux causes à les faire ou c'est
juste parce que il ya un problème est
que ça débouche sur il ya de toute
évidence il ya un problème mais mais le
fait de cette mobilisation
pousse pousse quand même d'une part à
l'indignation et pousse aussi et à la
peur de deux grands secteurs sociaux st
je vous lis on a vu ça en mai 68
rappelez-vous le résultat les résultats
électoraux poste mai 68 et bon ben moi
je crains que ce qui est en train de se
poser en europe céder certains vous avez
un cercle de pastis yeux ouverture est
fait la situation c'est à dire le
pouvoir à droite et la non solution des
problèmes particuliers pour cette
génération pousse une grande partie où
une partie de la génération des jeunes à
se révolter
cette révolte pousse les grandes masses
social a voté contre ce qu'elles
d'identifier avec c'est à dire avec la
gauche donc donc voilà où est ce qu est
ce que nous allons briser le cercle
lorsque nous allons réussir
c'est ce que nous en sortir dans les
semaines grand point d'interrogation les
semaines et les mois qui viennent mais
quel entrain de martinez merci beaucoup
en tout cas d'avoir accepté notre
invitation rester avec nous parce que
cette émission se poursuit avec notre
rubrique l'europe au quotidien vous
savez que chaque semaine nous répondons
à une question très concrète qui nous
est posée par un téléspectateur
aujourd'hui c'est une question de
stéphanie de lyon elle nous dit je vais
faire un très court séjour à rome et je
prévois de n'emporter qu'un bagage à
main dans l'avion est ce que j'ai le
droit de prendre mes produits de beauté
dans mon bagage à main voici la réponse
d'europe direct
vous avez le droit d'amener avec vous
vos produits cosmétiques dans la cabine
mais il faut il faut qu'il soit placier
dans des sachets en plastique
transparent et qu'ils ne dépassent pas
les 100 millilitres
s'il dépasse les 100 millilitres ils
devront être enregistrés et voyager dans
la soute
sauf s'il s'agit de médicaments ou
d'aliments pour enfants
voilà leur offre ça peut être
effectivement aussi des choses
extrêmement concrètes comme on vient de
le voir
merci encore d'avoir accepté en tout cas
de notre invitation
merci de votre fidélité à tous bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires